so very early on in this crisis we
welcome lieutenant governor of Texas dan
Patrick under this program he took a
very different point of view from that
of a lot of politicians at the time it
seemed brave agree or not but he was
savagely criticized for that he was said
that he was willing to assume some risk
he didn't want to die but he obviously
but he was willing to assume some risk
to himself as a man I was seventy for
the sake of his children and
grandchildren there's part of it I'm
gonna do everything I can to live but
you know if you said are you willing to
take a chance you know if I get sick
I'll go and try to get better but if I
don't I don't and I'm not trying to
think in any kind of morbid way Tucker
but I'm just saying that that we got a
choice here and and we're gonna be in a
total collapse recession depression
collapse in our society if this goes on
another several months there won't be
any jobs to come back to for many people
well it's been about a month since that
moment and we wanted to check in again
with lieutenant governor Patrick who
joins us tonight governor thanks so much
for coming on so you were pretty clear
in what you thought might happen in our
conversation a month ago you said if
this if they don't pull this back a
little bit you're gonna see a lot of
people out of work and you're gonna see
the economy crushed do you think you've
been vindicated well I'm sorry that I'm
vindicated I wish it hadn't happened
Tucker but I'm a small business guy and
I've been around the block long enough
to see what was going to happen when you
start shutting down society and people
start losing their paychecks and
businesses can't open and governments
aren't getting revenues and go on and on
and on and on so I'm sorry to say that I
was right on this and and I'm thankful
that we are now
Tucker finally beginning to open up
Texas and other states because it's been
long overdue you know they told us
Tucker to follow the science
well what science I mean at the end of
January dr. fowey who I have great
respect for said this wasn't a big issue
three weeks later we were going to lose
two million people another few weeks
later it was one to two hundred thousand
now it's under 60,000 and we've
the wrong numbers the wrong science and
I don't blame them
but let's face reality of where we are
in Texas we have 29 million people we've
lost 495 that every life is valuable but
500 people out of 29 million and we're
locked down and we're crushing the the
average worker we're crushing small
business we're crushing the markets
we're crushing this country and what I
said when I was with you that night
there are more important things than
living and that's saving this country
for my children and my grandchildren and
saving this country for all of us and I
don't want to die nobody wants to die
but maybe we got it we got to take some
risk and get back in the game and get
this country back up and running so in
the meantime in the month or so since
we've spoken your state which is in some
ways the most robust state in a lot of
ways out of 50 has really been hurt oil
futures down to negative 40 bucks today
which really is shocking Neiman Marcus
over a hundred year old company Texas
company Dallas company bankrupt yeah
bankrupt and you know an AOC you know
put a tweet up today she was glad to see
the oil industry collapse Tucker we we
cannot you know endure this much longer
you know every month we stay closed it's
going to take two to three months to
rebuild and the other things that the
president talked about and I think the
president on the same day that I was
with you one month ago to this Monday
night we both were saying the same thing
we can do two things at once and so
we've listened to the experts and we are
doing everything we can to protect life
and we have to the best of our ability
and except for New York and a few other
hotspots it's actually the death rate
has been low and again every life is
precious and don't diminish one life but
our country should not have been locked
down and now you know I've always said
if the Democrats ever had total control
they would put people like you and me in
jail and throw away the key and that's
what they're doing because they now have
total control Tucker they have total
control and everywhere you see this
draconian rules of locking down people
and keeping businesses shut and
destroying our country destroyed it's
mostly Democrat governors Democrat
county judges Democrat mayor's almost
every
where and when I saw the governor of New
Jersey last week say on your show you
know it's above my pay grade
then you need to resign that's what you
put your hand on the Bible when you take
office I don't care what office it is to
protect the Constitution of this United
States don't don't mock it don't mock it
so it's time to get back to work now he
said now and now he's arresting people
yeah arresting people who criticized him
that's that's handy lieutenant governor
thank you for coming on i I never defend
politicians but the abuse you took was
so ridiculously disconnected from what
you actually said that I wanted to have
you back thank you for that well thank
you I'm blessed God's good I'm fine
thank you